jetzt reden vier der promotoren in den
fängen des wendlers erste ex jetzt die
tochter der schlagerstar und die frauen
wie sehr schadet der wendler so seinen
ladys die dem ihm ein ausflug der sucht
zehn jahre nach dem ableben von super
star amy winehouse veröffentlicht ihr
freund taylor james ein buch über sie
freundschaftsdienst oder geldmacherei
vorteil nachname braune lange haare
grüne augen und stolze einen meter 85
groß die tochter von bayerns
ministerpräsident markus söder gloria
startet jetzt als model durch wie sehr
hilft die familie der karriere
darüber streiten jetzt janina kirsch
bild chefin yvonne weiß aus der bild
chefredaktion schneider schink bild
reporterin und nina schenk autorin jetzt
wegen vier der promi talk benutzt
michael wendler seine tochter adeline
als geschäftsführerin seiner firma damit
er seine schulden nicht zahlen muss das
zumindest behauptet ein ehemaliger
geschäftspartner des schlagerstars in
bild ja es sind harte anschuldigungen
aber ich muss sagen ich finde das nicht
ganz so weit hergeholt denn seine ex
frau hat er auch für gewisse finanzielle
zwecke benutzt die hat nämlich seine
firma geführt hat immer in seinem namen
geschäfte gemacht und am ende ist die
firma pleite gegangen er war nur
angestellter und sie musste haften und
ich kann nur sagen mir tun die frauen in
michael wendlers leben einfach nur noch
leid kann ich überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen wie du mit dem mitleid
haben kannst du ja wenn ich ganz ehrlich
bin ich meine die rennen ja selber sehen
des auges ins verderben
aber die ist doch erst 18 jahre alt du
kannst doch von einem 18-jährigen
mädchen nicht verlangen dass sie sich
gegen den mann auf lehnt den sie am
meisten von allen männern in der welt
vertraut nämlich eben eigenen vater wenn
dein vater zu dir sagt du wirst chef in
meiner firma dann bist du doch auch
nicht misstrauisch denn dann siehst du
das doch als chance und feucht ich also
mein vater sei nicht michael wendler
dominiert auch nicht die platte
hab ich froh meine mutter war ich in der
presse mit der geschichte giannina grad
schon vorgetragen hat und noch was
findest du dann auch nicht dass diese
frauen wählen gehen dürfen ich mal mit
18 jahren hat man das wahlrecht man darf
autofahren in amerika sogar schon mit 16
und jetzt sagen wir auch nein die arme
dies aber gar nicht schuld weil sie ist
ja es 18
das ist für mich völliger bullshit und
vor allem dummheit schützt vor strafe
nicht aber genauso wenig mitleid wie du
mit der tochter hast habe ich halt mit
laura also sorry laura wusste genau auf
was sie sich einlässt die berühmtheit
vom wendler das wollte sie alles sie
wollte in dem playboy und ich glaube
auch trotz dessen sie 20 jahre erst alt
ist sie hat es sehr bewusst gemacht und
ganz ehrlich mitgehangen mitgefangen
also ich weiss nicht mehr tut irgendwie
leid die ist ganz ganz jungen mit dem
zusammengekommen die war gerade 18 und
hatte hat ihre schule abgebrochen und
hatte überhaupt gar kein soziales netz
ja und lebt er jetzt mit dem in amerika
ist teilweise natürlich auch auf ihn
angewiesen einfach weil sie sonst
niemand anders hat und jetzt reißt er
sie in so ein abwärtsstrudel mit rein
und auch ihre karriere geht durch sein
fehlverhalten kaputt ich finde das ganz
ganz furchtbar und ehrlicherweise kammer
und hattet ihr noch nie rosarote brille
auf
na ja ich würde ganz kurz nach den
schinks hier warten
ich verstehe gar nicht warum er so hart
mit den frauen ins gericht geht ja wir
also die härtesten kritiker der frauen
sind immer frauen und nicht die männer
damit schwächen wir uns doch selbst
warum sind wir so so so harrt zu uns
selbst also wollen wir sprechen uns doch
eher wenn wir sagen dieses feines normal
ich meine dass müssen doch jetzt die
jungen mädchen sehen und denken ich
mache meine schule zu ende
ich gehe lieber studieren ich suche mir
keinen alten reichen knacker und b womit
schwächen wie sie wir können euch sagen
ach 30 passion immer dieses passion
dabei ist in münchen eigentlich alles
toll finde ich kann ich sagen auch die
arme ich empfinde mitleid mit ihr wenn
sie nur scheiße baut ist da muss ich
auch einmal sagen nina schenk und zink
sind sie glaube ich da einig ja aber die
beiden sich auch schon mal
beginnen wir mit diesem mann ich meine
musik klarer man weiß was ist denn mit
dir hast du noch nie eine rosarote
brille auf und hat dinge getan
aus liebe wo freunde gesagt haben ich
hatte das schon am freunde gesagt carina
ganz ehrlich der typ der tut mir nicht
gut und ich wollte das einfach nicht
sehen und erst im nachhinein habe ich
gedacht hätte ich mal auf meine freundin
gehört ja muss ich auch einmal zu geben
ist mir auch passiert ich hatte auch
richtig die rosarote brille auf tiefrot
war die und habe mich unsterblich
verliebt und dann ja es ist alles
zusammengebrochen ich stand vor einem
riesen drama obwohl ich nicht
fremdgegangen will oder sie jedenfalls
alle meine bluse vom balkon wasser
geschmissen
sie hat mich rausgeschmissen ich hatte
keine andere wohnung ich war quasi
obdachlos und die blusen die flogen dann
nur durch ja im streit schwer warum bist
du mit der zusammen gebleicht so
verliebt war und so blind und einfach
dachte diese frau wird ist mein leben
der aber und ich glaube laura liebe
leute ihr leben lassen
laura müller leben liebe machen auf
jeden fall blind genau und dein drama
ist auch ein drama aber wir kommen jetzt
noch einmal zu einem richtigen drama amy
winehouse eine der begnadete testen
künstlerin die es in ihrer zeit gab ihr
leben hatte sie aber überhaupt nicht
unter kontrolle
[Musik]
amy winehouse bei ihrem letzten auftritt
in belgrad
sie lag sie torkelt sie hat sich nicht
mehr im griff
und am ende wird sie ausgebaut
wenige tage später stürzt sie mit 4,16
promille im blut
das ist eine wahnsinnig tragische
geschichte zehn jahre ist das morgen her
und pünktlich zu ihrem todestag hat ihr
bester freund tyler james ein buch
geschrieben meine e-mail in der er ja
auch die letzten stunden des super-stars
sehr dramatisch schildert also du sagst
jetzt bester freund für mich ist das
kein freund für mich ist das die größte
plätze auf der welt muss ich sagen ein
guter freund verrät nicht all deine
geheimnisse was er in diesem buch alles
sagt ja wie amy faye dunaway beleidigte
wie ihr freund prinz geld klaut und sie
lachte noch darüber
und dann hatte sie mal so eine
gesichtsmaske auf und ist total
betrunken über betten gehüpft und und
hatte über dildos besuchen ganz ehrlich
ein freund erzählt so was nicht und es
gibt da nämlich ein strich strich worten
sprichwort das passt sehr gut zu wir
werden uns nicht an die worte unserer
feinde erinnern sondern an das schweigen
unserer freundin aber ich muss jetzt mal
eine sache sagen er sagt selber über das
buch dass es eine form von therapie für
ihn war das aufzuschreiben weil er
gemerkt hat dass er mit dem tod nicht
richtig haben so recht gekommen ist und
er sie als beispiel genommen hat weil
wir schreiben also texte schreiben immer
geholfen hat also hat er einfach
angefangen zu schreiben
und er sagt dass er ihre geschichte
erzählen will also er möchte wissen
möchte zeigen dass die menschen sie wo
er will dass die menschen den menschen
winehouse sehen und halt nicht nur diese
kunstfigur könnte kann aber dass nicht
er sagt das aber dennoch glaube ich dass
die einzige motivation hinter diesem
buch geld ist er wasser machen zu ihrem
zehnten todestag sowie für den man nicht
mal ein buch kleiner einwurf man für die
sie als autorin wahrscheinlich ein euro
pro stück da muss er schon richtig viel
verkaufen
und man darf ja nicht vergessen dass der
mann durch gemacht hat die beiden sind
befreundet das ist seitdem sie zwölf und
13 waren
er hat
alles mit ihr durch gemacht ihre cracks
ihre heroinabhängigkeit ihre ihre
alkoholabhängigkeit er war in jeder
situation bei
also ich meine der mann hat auch genug
also ich finde es jetzt nicht so schlimm
ich habe hier mal rein gelesen ich finde
dass er sich halt so total als held
darstellen will mit diesem buch ich war
damals der letzte freund der ihnen noch
geblieben war der einzige mensch der
ständig bei ihr war ohne dafür bezahlt
zu werden
alle anderen hatten sich vertreter
vielleicht so er war da aber im
entscheidenden moment war eben auch
nicht da und deshalb glaube ich dass er
sich hier nur seine schuldgefühle der
sommerstadt ganz ehrlich was möchtest du
denn dass er an ihrem bett sitzt und
immer darauf wartet dass hat er lange
getan
ob möglicherweise ihr herz aufhört zu
schlagen das können menschen doch nach
ich da muss ich auch einmal ein
schreiben er sagt ja auch er hat sie
geliebt wie seine schwester und ganz
ehrlich wenn er sie wirklich so sehr
geliebt hat wie seine schwester dann
hätte er sich eigentlich fallen lassen
müssen aber klar hätte er ja hätte
erkannt kein mehr bei drogensüchtigen
dann muss ich auch einmal noch mal das
wort ergreifen noch bei drogensüchtigen
ist es leider so dass du sie nur retten
kannst wenn du sie fallen lässt auch
wenn es im herzen ganz ganz ganz schwer
ist es leider so wir sind nicht
erfahrungen genau also ich habe im
engsten familienkreis tatsächlich
jemanden der seit zehn jahren kokain
abhängig ist und damit haben wir
natürlich alle zu kämpfen und wir sind
auch so weit dass man das sich beratung
einholt und jeder berater jeder
psychologe sagt einem es geht nur so
weit wenn du ihnen fallen lässt dann
wird er irgendwann so weit unten liegen
das hat dann versteht wo ich bin hier
völlig um nichts ich bin hier völlig
allein
dann hört er erst auf sich irgendwas
rhein zu knallen die sucht sozusagen
weiter voranzuschreiten weil er dann vor
dem nichts steht aber halt so selbst
schon mal geschafft dann auch so stark
zu sein und den wirklich fallen zu
lassen musste ich auch mal ist
tatsächlich sehr sehr schwer gewesen
also ich hab ein anderes bekommen zum
beispiel morgens um acht ich war gerade
auf dem weg ins büro und dann sagt er
kannst du mich abholen kann
nach durchzechter nacht durchgemacht wie
man das anscheinend einzukreisen macht
und dann habe ich gesagt nee ich kann
mich jetzt nicht abholen natürlich
wollte ich sofort losfahren und den
abholen da war mir auch das büro egal
er ist also ich habe in meinem
kanten kreis auch ein zwei fälle wo
leute in frühen jahren drogenabhängig
wurden und es heute auch noch sind und
ich kann aus diesen erfahrungen nur
sagen ich verstehe jede eltern ich
verstehe jede mutter jeden vater jede
besten freund auch jeden freund der
diese menschen nicht fallen lässt und
ich glaube ich bewunderte man das kann
weil ich glaube da bin ich beide ist
wahrscheinlich der beste weg ist aber
ich verstehe jeden menschen der es nicht
kann und ich würde auch lieber die hand
reichen er sagt ich schaff's nicht
schwer stellung ich könnte niemals meine
kinder fallen lassen egal was sie tun
also liebe top jede vernunft und ganz
ehrlich ich gehe lieber mit den unter
als dass die abstürzen und was wäre das
auch für leben dann ich könnte ja gar
nicht mit dem gedanken glücklich sein
dass die unter irgendeiner brücke zu tal
total zugedröhnt sind also das wäre ja
dann für mich auch kein leben mehr
glaube da muss jeder einfach seine
eigenen erfahrungen machen und jeder für
sich selbst entscheiden wir am besten
für sich und auch mit seinen für sein
eigenes gewissen damit umgehen kann
aber wir wollen noch einmal zu einem
etwas schöneren und lebens vorderen
thema komme schreibt ein paar bilder
mitgebracht von einer sehr sehr schön
die jungen frau sie ist 1 meter 85 groß
und startet jetzt als model durch sie
kennen sie vielleicht noch nicht und
helium studio vielleicht auch noch nicht
aber auf jeden fall kennen sie ihren
vater das ist nämlich bayerns
ministerpräsident markus söder ja nur
mir so viel springt damit auf einen
trend auf den ja auch viele andere promi
kinder schon vorgemacht haben lediglich
step kagawa alle wahnsinnig erfolgreich
nicht unüblich mittlerweile und warum so
genau warum so erfolgreich wegen des
nachnamens bin mir ziemlich sicher dass
die ganz klar wissen ich nutze meinen
vorteil ich die wissen schon was sie tun
und vor allem auch so eine linie klum
ich meine die ausbildung hat sie noch
nicht mal angefangen aber die karriere
geht schon steil nach oben
also wenn man also apropos leni klum
leni klum hat gerade vier wochen in
einem eiscafé gejobbt und hat eis
verkauft das finde ich schon sehr
bodenständig hat ihre mama und sie auf
instant kurse finde ich aber sehr
bodenständig und was ich noch sagen muss
ich würde es doch genauso
also wenn ich jetzt den vorteil hätte
durch den vater oder durch die mutter
würde ich den nutzen und vor allem was
mir so unfassbar auf den geist geht das
immer so mit schlink ist dieses eliten
bashing in deutschland es ist fast so
als müsste man sich dafür schämen für
den nach dem angriff das was man macht
und ich muss dir wirklich sagen ich habe
zum beispiel ist mal fernab der promi
welt
ich kenne viele die familienunternehmen
übernommen haben und ich sage heute und
am anfang war ich auch mal so naja die
grünen uns ja nicht selber und heute
sage ich werde da reingeht in jungen
jahren sich dahin stellt dieses
unternehmen vorantreiben die nächste
generation überträgt hat für mich auf
mehr geleistet als sie das startup und
stelle eine große verantwortung
um auch aus einer unternehmerfamilie und
ich habe mich nicht ins gemachte nest
ich finde ich an der wir auch gemacht
dass die menschen die so was getan haben
mir ihre träume erfüllt haben sondern
das gemacht haben was die eltern wollen
mensch wo es ist und ich noch mein team
vertraut und mir wurde immer gesagt du
machst das was deine leidenschaft ist
und der bin ich nachgegangen und ich
hatte kein bock das weiter zu tragen
weil es der einfachste weg für mich ist
mich halt in so ein einfach gemacht doch
jetzt dass er dich da auch janina aber
wir können doch nicht die verurteilen
die das tun warum denn auch die welt ist
voller ungerechtigkeiten und dann hat
mal jemand eine chance warum sollen die
denn nicht nutzen kaya gerber war die
dir habe ich mal gesehen bei einer show
von karl lagerfeld natürlich
wahrscheinlich wie cindy crawford ihrer
mutter hat sie überhaupt die chance
bekommen aber die chancen nutzen das
musste sie ja dann schon alleine und die
ist über diesen laufsteg geschwebt also
das war wirklich eine erscheinung das
heißt sie hat dann auch leistung
gebracht ich habe auch nie gesagt um das
mal klarzustellen dass ich etwas
verurteile ich habe nur gesagt für mich
würde es nicht in frage kommen und für
mich driftet es schon in four teilnahme
ab also ich muss sagen wenn du jetzt
nennt das beispiel von cindy crawfords
tochter
sie nutzt doch aus und ganz viele mehr
niedernhausen aber die da draußen
hübschen schön sind kriegen diese chance
nicht und dann muss ich die hand nahmen
einige von denen haben schon ihre
karriere begonnen haben aber noch nicht
mal eine ausbildung das sag ich doch ihr
geht immer davon nicht jede supermodels
abitur und hatte sie studiert also
schade die meisten wolle jetzt haben wir
jetzt keinen bachelor oder
masterabschluss und darf nicht auch es
muss doch ist aber auch wirklich
es gibt auch ist im feld macht ihr klar
geworden dass wahrscheinlich war eben um
ihr habt das das erleichtert die hat
noch nicht mal richtige modelmaße
darüber dass ich etwas nicht gebucht
wurden fürs cover devrient wie heute ist
darin valo es geht um follower und
hockeyclub er war das denn wir doch dass
sie so eine berühmte mutter hat außerdem
ihr geht immer davon aus dass nachnamen
vorteil ist ja das kann auch ein
nachteil sein meine mutter werk und
schon der retten was meinst du was da
los war an manchen schützenfesten und
wenn man sich mut angetrunken hat mir
erzählt dass wir vettel hier runter ich
habe also ein nachname öffnet nicht nur
türen ja es kommt darauf an welcher
nachname also johnny depp zb hätte ich
auch nicht gern als vater nicht aber als
lover oder als lava darüber reden wir
wenn die kamera aus
aber sonst ist alles später ich alle
spieler ja gut dann würde ich sagen
die zeit ist auch schon wieder oben
perfektes timing an besseren abschluss
kann es doch nicht geben mit einem
großen lacher im gesicht ich bedanke
mich fürs zuschauen ich bedanke mich bei
euch hier im studio und alles weitere
natürlich wie immer auf bild.de